[Musique]
mardi soir dernier en plein hémicycle
alors que la députée de la france
insoumise matile panneaux pour des la
parole elle a été interpellée par un de
ses confrères une insulte qui n'est pas
du tout passé
pour la députée qui ignorait à ce moment
là l'auteur de ces paroles il était
essentiel que des exclus soient
formulées pour cette attaque qu'elle
juge sexistes est totalement déplacé
c'est pas pour une raison personnelle
mais c'est parce que si on laisse à
l'assemblée nationale des parlementaires
femmes se faire régulièrement insulté
alors en fait on a une institution de
notre république qui acceptent le
sexisme ordinaire je ne connais aucune
femme politique qui n'en a pas été
victime l'auteur de cette insulte a été
finalement identifié comme étant
monsieur pierre henriette député la
république en marche de la d insulte la
députée attend surtout des sanctions sur
twitter elle a publié la réponse du
président de l'assemblée nationale qui
indique condamné lui aussi ces dérives
alors un député trêve de poissonnière
une opposante doit-il être sanctionné
raquel garrido et en direct avec nous
pour nous donner son point de vue à 2h24
on est en direct et je voudrais le dire
parce que je veux lui dire aux
téléspectateurs ce soir oui si on fait
pas de politique
non mais c'est vrai voilà dans touche
pas à mon poste on en fait pas et c'est
vrai qu'on n'a jamais été plus à droite
à gauche au milieu mais je le dis
qu'elles soient de n'importe quel bord
raquel garrido aujourd'hui c'est devenu
une et je le dis voilà franchement c'est
vrai qu'on peut sans brouiller sur les
plateaux télé mais elle sait que je les
adore et à chaque fois qu'on est dans
les loges ou ailleurs en dehors c'est un
amour et elle sait que je laime fort
voilà je voudrais dire mais c'est vrai
ma chérie et je voudrais dire à quel
garrido qu'on soit d'accord avec elle
voilà sur ses idées sur ces trucs nous
on est on est d'accord pratiquement sur
rien on va sur beaucoup de choses quand
même c'est vrai exactement non c'est
vrai sur beaucoup de choses à donner du
même mars on a là un sujet comme en vrai
on est quand même on est d'accord à 80
5% s'embrouille beaucoup mais c'est vrai
que c'est une personne voilà je vous le
dis que j'aime
voilà je dis non mais c'est vrai que tu
es une personne formidable dans la vie
et après voilà tu défends mes idées mais
je t'aime beaucoup wallon à mercier
c'est vrai qu'elle agirait alors on a vu
mardi soir à l'assemblée
maty de panneaux donc de la france
insoumise et bien elle s'est fait
traiter de poissonnière est ce que le
député ayant injurié la députée
insoumise mathy de panneaux doit être
donc sanctionné
un petit panneau elle veut qu'ils soient
sanctionnés parce qu'il a il a fait des
excuses et s'excuser comme on l'a dit
dans récapitulatif mais elle veut bien
sûr qu'ils soient sanctionnés alors on
va laisser les chroniqueurs âge et ma
part je voudrais qu'on ait larmes la
réponse de raquel garrido vous vous
dites non vraiment je pense qu'il faut
arrêter de voir du sexisme partout déjà
de monsieur en question l'auteur de ces
propos il s'est excusé ensuite elle
n'est pas tendre non plus avec les
politiques et la traite et christophe
castaner de déchets puis j'ai
l'impression que ça fait aussi partie de
la culture de l'assemblée nationale ne
se lancer des vannes de se lancer des
piques ont montré encore il ya quelques
jours des députés qui taclait un peu
jean michel blanquer
je pense qu'elle va s'en remettre c'est
pas dramatique et je pense qu'il ya pas
de sexisme là dedans c'est plus des
moqueries alors gilles guillaume a
totalement tort c'est du sexisme pur et
dur il faut qu'ils soient sanctionnés et
durement poissonnière mais vous rendez
compte dans un symbole une institution
l'assemblée nationale poissonnière c'est
tout moi je voulais pas risquer sans
avoir à tourner c'est la manière dont
ils n'ont médias
c'est absolument pas la profession dont
il parle c'est pour lui c'était une
injure
et moi je dis un député qui injurie il
n'est pas digne de représenter ce que le
déchet c'est mieux alors il s'est pas
passé par un oeil pour oeil dent pour
dent à l'assemblée que lui et moi alors
gilles justement il me semble que toutes
les filles si oui a dit non donc c'est
vrai en fait y'a rien de sexiste
c'est bon il a dit poissonnière et en
plus six il s'est excusé donc que la
personne disent je veux qu'ils se
fassent sanctionné je trouve ça laid
hyper loin on sait très bien que dans
l'hémicycle les esprits s'échauffent et
c'est le jeu et macau la peur ni coop ou
alors moi je pense c'est que ce sont en
majorité des garçons qui soit que le
défilé soit sanctionné
j'y passais d'accord avec géraldine
jeudi juste il doit être qu'il doit être
exemplaire il est député c'est encore
l'argent public c'est pas une question
de sexisme c'est d'abord d'abord il
n'est pas très présent à l'assemblée
il faut le savoir en général donc j'ai
regardé un peu son son cv comme
maintenant pourquoi pourquoi ça
n'existait pas il ya 20 ans 25 ans je
bougeais pas de cette manière là mais
bien là aujourd'hui le mec il arrive il
traitait d'une poissonnière venir ça n'a
aucun sens attention c'est que si ces il
s'est expliqué pourquoi il a dit pascal
voici ferrées etc a passé son temps à
couper la parole alors certes c'est pas
très élégant mais il n'y a rien de
sexiste là dedans alors géraldine oui en
fait quand on s'y fait une femme à
l'assemblée nationale s'agit d'une côté
sexiste et c'est dégueulasse il dérange
ipsa d'accord mais après effectivement
c'est une sorte de sales gosses
indisciplinés ils s'excusaient moi je
trouve que dix mètres du sexisme partout
alors à ce moment-là quand monsieur
mélenchon dit machine schiappa mais
c'est sexiste aussi bien qu'à ce moment
là il faut le voilà moi je trouve que
c'est pas très grave il ya aussi des
joutes un petit peu oratoire et vous
êtes avocat vous le savez et a parfois
ses abonnés sur gracq et la d1 des
formules un peu forts qui font un peu
louche et je trouve ça fait aussi partie
du jeu démocratique voilà qu'est ce que
c'est que cette culture de la sanction
l'ornement logo sexisme qui ne désigne
en rien les femmes
donc je sais pas pourquoi on se
l'approprié brusquement ce mot et puis
tu systématiquement avoir un
comportement ultra exigé des excuses des
sanctions et tout mais pardon je pense
que ni la démocratie ni la cause des
femmes n'a rien à y gagner
franchement effectivement quand on
regarde les propos de la jeune personne
elle est pourrie va aussi fort également
donc on est passé sans transition de
l'homme n'ont aucune excuse à l'homme à
tous les la femme à tous les droits
alors c'est pas bien raquel garrido déjà
vous comment vous avez réagi quand vous
avez vu que maty de panneaux avaient été
traités de poissonnière à la santé
j'étais ulcérée parce que moi qui suis
une militante de longue date et une
femme qui prend la parole on va dire
d'une façon un peu
opiniâtre oui ça soit je vous le
confirmer
j'ai l'habitude j'ai l'habitude de
recevoir ce genre de coup en dessous de
la ceinture
plusieurs petits panneaux à la pâleur de
se laisser faire quand même c'est un
quart à l'acte et c'est peut-être pour
ça d'ailleurs qu'à des hommes voilà il
ya des hommes qui se sentent menacés par
les femmes qui sont voilà qui est qu'ils
ont de la verve qui se laisse pas faire
il ya des hommes qui ne l'acceptent pas
et est du coup il n'arrive pas à retenir
leur langue et dans et dans cette
configuration de l'assemblée nationale
qu' une configuration très spécial où
effectivement la liberté de parole est
forte ou historiquement je m'aime je
sais pas si vous le savez mais il ya une
immunité la parole dans l'hémicycle
c'est à dire qu' on ne peut pas
poursuivre un parlementaire pour les
mots qu'il a prononcés dans les
mythiques parce qu'on veut que nous
parlementaires disent tous qu'ils
pensent alors que jamais ils
s'autocensurent mais du coup ça veut
dire que l'assemblée nationale elle même
doit faire la police vu que la police je
veux dire mettre en place des règles
parce que la société peuvent affaire la
justice ne peut pas le faire il ya une
immunité donc la règle le l'assemblée
doit décider qu'est ce qui est de
l'ordre de cette liberté de ton et
qu'est ce qui ne l'est pas et moi alors
c'est ma position je pense qu'il ya une
limite c'est voilà tout ce qui est
d'ordre sexistes ou racistes
alors je pense qu'en 2021 c'est une
limite qu'on peut à quelle douce mettre
en place et est d'accord pour dire
partager ça n'a pas fait un peu trop
matip panneaux pour faire parler d'elle
haussier si le bien que je vais me
servir de ça pour faire parler de moi
pour faire un buzz et pour que derrière
donc connaissance gosse la connaissez
pas votre panneau grâce à ça maintenant
je la connais alors est-ce que c'est pas
un agent non mais qu'est ce qui vous
dérange
honnêtement dans le fait qu'ils aient
dit la possonnière inconséquence et sert
bien que c'est dans un contexte
particulier où il ya un échange en quoi
ses hôtes a raison et que vous supposiez
qu'il y avait un échange et où que par
exemple qu'elle avait qu'elle avait
interrompu qu'elle lui donnait là alors
qu'en fait non elle montait à la tribu
pour prendre la parole sur la
prolongation de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire question importante s'il en
est et sa simple montée des marches à la
tribune a provoqué une sorte de brouhaha
avec un gars kaka quand même dit la
folle voilà la folle et l'autre la
poissonnière alors vous pouvez vous dire
que c'est pas du sexisme pardon mais
alors ça quand même
de nadine morano à ce moment-là vous
dire la même chose ne vous a pas
beaucoup entendus
on s'inscrit mise dire aussi par exemple
en théologie khaldi moi là dessus je
suis très constante jeu des fonds
toujours les femmes victimes de jets
voit qu'elle a déjà fait craquer le
chemin n'a pas ou alors elle l'a fait
systématiquement est là le signe qu'elle
soit consciente juste moi c'est une
question de cohérence
et je crois beaucoup et enfin de plus en
plus parce que je vieillis comme tout le
monde et j'adore je deviens plus
sororale jeu que je compte bien les
choses il ya dix ans il ya 15 ans il ya
vingt ans en tant que femme je n'étais
pas nécessairement dans la sororité jeu
des fois je me laisser embarquer dans
des pièges que nous jette les hommes
pour nous jeter les femmes les unes
contre les autres et maintenant que je
suis plus voilà peu dans l'attenté d'un
usage plus dans la sororité là j'ai
l'impression avant que tu vois la
sororité n'a plus raté d'ailleurs au
regard des 1
il ya des députés femmes en marche qui
ont soutenu mathilde canaux
immédiatement tout de suite après que
les la parole a été prononcé il ya elles
broutent privé s'est approché d'elle et
c'est il ya des femmes et et alors quant
aux sanctions
alors ça va être quoi la sanction alors
je voulais des champions mais évidemment
aubin je rappelle que françois ruffin
s'est fait enlever un quart de son
indemnité parlementaire sur un mois
parce qu'il avait un maillot de foot ou
parce qu'il y avait abandonné des
échanges un peu la voix plus haut que
l'autre donc à un moment donné ça suffit
il ya là une députée les autres les
parlementaires se sont mis à bel-air
mais jamais rien eu
il ya une série de dispositions de l'art
m voici moi j'ai eu hier deux députés
qui se sont fait traiter de petite conne
c'est l'antidote à elsa fossiles
hexagonal s'est fait belle fille mercy
maintenant il faut il faut voilà je dis
pas qu'il faudrait t dessus des plombes
mais il faut marquer le coup pour
avancer et que ce ce pierre comment il
s'appelle henry y ait un billet en rien
pierre henry y est que je ne connaissais
pas pour le coup parce que matt hill
panne on l'a vu sur des combats ont
conduit le temps mais je ne connaissais
pas alors j'ai vu voilà donc s'il sait
qui il est maire fils de mère est bon de
vendée on peut pas décemment qui pensent
qu'il est dans l'impunité totale et il
ne comprend pas parce que c'est pas vrai
qu'il s'est excusé vous avez dit qu'il
s'était excusé ce n'est pas vrai il a
dit je n'ai rien fait de mal mais si ça
peut être mal perçu machin il avait là
10 et panne alors on va voir mais je les
fais parce que l interrompt tout le
monde
il s'est auto excuses et enfin non à 58
% moyenne tandis qu'elle doit pas être
sanctionné syrie elle va merci s'il vous
plaît je vous laisse à meilhan dire que
malheureusement il ya un renouvellement
1,2 des députés depuis 2010 est ce sont
des jeunes
et malheureusement ils ont déjà pris le
tout les codes des anciens c'est à dire
la grossière et dire des conneries à
l'assemblée et c est ça c'est bien
regretter alors lui malgré la
progression de la part irak elle et lui
lui il est toujours alizés il évoque lui
les stades lot à la raison de lui oui
mais c'est vrai que lui où il est né en
1991 est donc ça aurait pu penser qu'il
fait partie d'une génération est bonne
et un peu plus attention à la belle
époque mais l'âme à l'assemblée et moi
je n'avais pas des femmes à l'assemblée
doit c'est pas compliqué vous y
attendent noir et l'ehpad arabe
donc évidemment il n'y avait pas non
plus beaucoup de passes et mieux
maintenant fou ce matin c'est le
mouvement et ça veut dire aussi que les
personnes qui ont comme ça d d d d
expression des interjections spontanée
de racisme de sexisme bafoukay garde ça
dans leur poche et je pense qu'on en
vient tous grandi